Heute im Rasenfunk. Das ist ein Mädchen, ein unglaubliches Mädchen. Der Frankfurter schießt Eintracht Frankfurt in die Bundesliga.
Eckball, Langer fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Der S ist vor allem das A- und P-Team steht für attraktiv und preiswert in der Bundesliga. Und jetzt ist das letzte Kapitel im verrücktesten Fußballmärchen der Saison geschrieben.
Ach, ihr lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer, diejenigen von euch, die das jetzt nur in Anführungszeichen hören und nicht bei YouTube sehen, euch entgehen immer die Reaktionen meiner Gäste auf dieses Intro. Das war schon beim letzten Mal sehr interessant. Und diesmal auch. Es changierte zwischen Begeisterung und Fassungslosigkeit. Und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk in der Ligatur in unserem Format, in dem wir auf andere Ligen blicken als eben die ersten Ligen bei den Männern und bei den Frauen. Dazu ist gestern eine Folge erschienen über die Copa Libertadores. Und heute natürlich, das ist ja dann quasi die deutsche Copa Libertadores, die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Über die wollen wir heute sprechen. Schön, dass ihr da seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und auf Blue Sky. Und ich begrüße hier eine schöne Runde bei mir. Zum einen mit ihrem Rasenfunk-Debüt von der Sportshow unter anderem. Lisa Höfer, hallo Lisa, schön, dass du hier bist.
Okay, also jetzt hast du uns dann quasi erklärt, wo so die Baustellen im Kader liegen. Und auch schon eigentlich relativ gut, wie auch diese unterschiedlichen banklämütigen Ergebnisse zustande kommen. Und jetzt sagst du ja, das hat viel auch damit zu tun, wie eben strukturell der KSC aufgestellt ist oder personell quasi in der sportlichen Leitung und ja auch im Vorstand und so weiter und so fort. Was hat sich denn seit unserer letzten Folge, die ich natürlich verlinken werde, weil das können wir unmöglich wieder alles nacherzählen. Und ehrlicherweise, ich habe auch das Board, was ich mir damals gemacht habe, mit den ganzen roten Fäden und so weiter, das habe ich leider letzte Woche entsorgt. Deswegen geht das nicht mehr. Das waren natürlich aber blaue Fäden, fällt mir gerade ein. Was hat sich denn seitdem getan?
Na gut, getan hat sich, da muss man eben ein bisschen in den Sommer zurückgehen. Getan hat sich, du hattest mir, glaube ich, auch geschrieben mit dieser Struktur im sportlichen Bereich. Haben Sie sich dann im Juni entschieden, dass quasi Michael Becker der eigentliche kaufmännische Chefsführer jetzt der Gesamtgeschäftsführer wird? Und dass darunter nur noch drei Bereichsleiter sind. Der Bereichsleiter Scouting, Entwicklung, Analyse, der Bereichsleiter Akademie, sprich NLZ, und eben der Bereichsleiter Profis. Und die zwei Stellen, Scouting und NLZ, wurden schnell besetzt. Unter anderem mit dem Vater von Michael Becker, also quasi Edde Becker, berichtete zu seinem Sohn. Und Michael Bischoff, der hat Scouting gemacht, und Bereichsleitung Profis blieb erst mal umbesetzt bis Ende August. Da haben sie sich dann für Sebastian Freis entschieden, der mehr oder weniger aus seinem eigenen Stall kam. Und, nee, nicht mehr oder weniger. Er kommt aus dem eigenen Stall, de facto. Und war Teil der sogenannten Task Force. Weil der KSC nach dem Rausschmiss von Oliver Kreuzer eine Task Force eingesetzt hat, die sich eben um Transfers gekümmert hat. Dementsprechend, ja.
Also der KSC hat eine Task Force gebildet. Der KSC hat sich einfallen lassen, dass man einen Chef hat und darunter drei Bereichsleiter. Ist der KSC die Vereinsinkarnation des DFB? Oder ist es nicht ganz so schlimm?
Na ja, man wird sehen, wie am Ende der Output ist, glaube ich. Ich finde halt lustig, dass diese Organisation, und das wurde irgendwie auch in der Presse gar nicht so richtig aufgegriffen, meiner Meinung nach, dass man das mal so zumindest reflektiert. Dass quasi der geschäftsführer, kaufmännische Geschäftsführer und der sportliche Geschäftsführer Ende März in eine Sitzung gehen. Es bleibt der kaufmännische Geschäftsführer übrig und der ist plötzlich botzt von allen. Dieser Vorgang ist so ein bisschen, habe ich irgendwie ein Störgefühl, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Am Ende des Tages sind sie wohl mit Carsten Rothenbach vom FC St. Pauli, der im NLZ tätig ist, Team Manager der U23, sind sie wohl in weiten Verhandlungen. Die Presse steckt das durch. Carsten Rothenbach sagt offensichtlich ab, also so war es der Presse zu entnehmen. Der KSC präsentiert einen Tag später diese Neustrukturierung. Die lag ja in der Schublade. Offensichtlich war der Druck so groß, dass sie sagen müssen, okay, stimmt. Ist halt so. So wie ich Sportdirektoren kennengelernt habe in den letzten Jahren, frage ich mich, wie einfach ist es, jemanden zu finden, der eine Bereichsleitung übernimmt, der nicht Chef ist?
Ja, und vor allem der an jemanden berichtet, der keinen sportlichen Fokus hat. Das ist ja auch noch so was, was häufig auf dieser Position eine Rolle spielt.
Und am Ende kommt man halt dann mit der Hauslösung raus, die wahrscheinlich, weil das macht A und B, weil es ja auch finanzierbar ist. Du hattest es gerade schon angesprochen, dann sind wir nämlich beim Thema gewissermaßen. Nachdem Sebastian Freis aus dieser Taskforce zum BL Sport ernannt wurde, oder BL Profis, Bereichsleiter Profis, hat ein weiteres Mitglied der Taskforce, der technische Leitersport, Netschad Aigün, wurde eben verkündet auf der Homepage, dass der geht. Und er hat unter anderem im Zitat gesagt, es war eine positive und konstruktive Zusammenarbeit. Einen Monat später gibt Netschad Aigün, der nicht geschafft, das ist ja falsch, einvernehmlich wurde der Vertrag aufgelöst offiziell, gibt der Badischen Neuesten Nachrichten ein längeres Interview, wo er gerade das anspricht. Also, dass jetzt in den letzten Monaten der wirtschaftliche Leiter zu viel Macht hatte, im Endeffekt hat er über Transfers entschieden und so weiter und so fort. Also im Endeffekt, es ist immer schwer, Leute wollen sich ja dann quasi positionieren in der Presse, deshalb weiß man ja nie, was dahinter steckt, sage ich mal, aber dass es sehr, sehr grummelt im Verein, dafür war dieses Interview quasi das beste Beispiel. Was macht der KSC? Der KSC stellt sich hin und zerlegt das Interview von Netschad Aigün in seine Einzelteile auf der Homepage mit einer Stellungnahme. Wo ich mir denke, Leute, müsst ihr über dieses Stöckchen springen. Also ehrlich, so viel erzählt er ja nicht.
Aber Jörn, da kennst du dich wahrscheinlich einfach zu schlecht mit Pressearbeit aus. Ach nee, Moment. Ach so. Du hast genau das mal beruflich gemacht beim FC St. Pauli. Dann weiß ich jetzt auch nichts.
Außerdem hättest du es ja auch an der PK zerlegen können. Eben. Wäre noch viel schlimmer gewesen.
Naja, also im Endeffekt dröselt der KSC es so auf, was denn jetzt falsch war und stellt klar, was da jetzt falsch war, was er da so und so rausschmeißer, der Klassiker. Keiner steht über dem KSC. Wer meldet sich als nächstes? Der Vizepräsident. Vizepräsident vom KSC war in diesem Fall der Müller. Martin Müller stellt sich, der quasi mit Günter Pilarski, als Oliver Kreuzer entlassen wurde im Frühjahr, sehr öffentlichkeitswirksam klargemacht hat, dass diese Entscheidung richtig doof war, weil die Entscheidung auch 3 zu 2 fiel. Der Beirat, der quasi Geschäftsführer ist, besteht beim KSC immer aus Präsidium, Vizepräsidenten und 2 Beisitzern. Und lustigerweise sind die Vizepräsidenten die, die für eine Weiterbeschäftigung von Kreuzer gestimmt hatten eigentlich. Auf jeden Fall meldet sich Müller und sagt so suffisant in der Presse, naja, an dem, was Netschert Aigün gesagt hat und wo er Einblick hat, kann er eigentlich nichts Falsches entdecken. Der Karlsruher Sportclub reagiert erneut mit einem offenen Brief.
Das wird ja jetzt immer besser, Jörn. Also ich muss mir das jetzt auch gleich aufzeichnen, so wie Max das schon angeteasst hat.
Vor allem beim KSC weiß man nie, vielleicht sind wir immer noch erst im Juli.
Das ist jetzt quasi das, was ich angesprochen habe. Das Interview war quasi im Oktober und die Reaktion auf dieses Interview kam direkt so 13. oder 14.
Oktober rum.
Du hast mich ja immer up to date gehalten.
Deswegen, ja. Auch die Reaktion des Vizepräsidenten kam prompt und auch wiederum die Reaktion des Vereins kam prompt mit dem offenen Brief, wo im Endeffekt gesagt wird, da sind wir nämlich, was Michi auch meinte, dass der eingeschlagene Weg, also sprich diese Umstrukturierung, ist eben die Grundlage für die Wahrscheinlichkeit, den sportlichen und wirtschaftlichen Erfolg zu erhöhen. Und natürlich geht es nicht ohne Geburtsschmerzen, sage ich mal, ab. Und ja, man muss halt quasi zusammenhalten und man ist in einer schweren, sportlichen Situation usw. usf. so in die Richtung. Dieser Brief wird unterschrieben von über 30 KSC-Mitarbeitern, also auch leitende Angestellte, unter anderem von Präsidenten, von Aufsichtsrat usw. usf. Dieser Brief wird nur nicht unterschrieben von den beiden Vizepräsidenten.
Also 2 zu 30 wurde dieser Brief verabschiedet, sagen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Ja, genau. Mit dem Argument, die Formulierung in dem Brief ist, dass es eine umfangreiche Analyse gab, die eben zu dieser Reorganisation des sportlichen Gesamtbereichs geführt hat. Und da hat der Vizepräsident in der Presse dann wiederum gesagt, die gab es ja gar nicht.
Es ist ja wirklich wie beim BVB. Das ist ja wie beim Frauenteam.
Die gab es ja nicht, deshalb dementsprechend wollte er sich nicht identifizieren. Im Endeffekt hat er das Ding nur vorgelegt gekommen und sollte unterschreiben und das hat er überhaupt nicht eingesehen usw. Der Fan-Dachverband, die Supporters, die im Frühjahr noch gesagt haben, ja, man muss alles aus der Öffentlichkeit raushalten usw. hat dann wiederum eine Stellungnahme rausgegeben und gesagt, sie haben sichere Informationen, dass Vizepräsident Martin Müller interner an die Presse weitergeleitet hat. Und er hat dann wiederum über die Presse verlaubt werden lassen. Er sei völlig respektlos und amateurhaft und unprofessionell. Das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Am Ende ist es so, der Aufsichtsratsvorsitzende Grenke hat versucht, es zu löschen. Aktuell ist es auch gelöscht in dem Sinne. Die Mitgliederversammlung findet Anfang Dezember statt. Die wird übers Schicksal des Präsidiums entscheiden. Was vielleicht auch wichtig ist bei der Stellungnahme der Supporters, weil es wurde vermutet, dass der Vizepräsident eigene Ambitionen hat, Präsident zu werden. Die Supporters haben schon droppen lassen nach dem Motto, du gehst hier überhaupt kein Präsident, sondern wenn, dann wird hier die Vertrauensfrage gegen dich gestellt. Der Fan-Dachverband der Supporters ist mächtig. Das sind die meisten Leute auf der Mitgliederversammlung. Ich gehe davon aus, dass er eher das Vertrauen verlieren würde, als Präsident zu werden. Aber das ist eine persönliche Einschätzung. Das ist jetzt der Stand. Christian Eichner hat auch auf der Pressekonferenz nach Schalke, dass das Spiel 3-0 gewonnen wurde, verlautbaren lassen, dass er in dem Sinn stolz auf seine Mannschaft ist, dass er sich total auf Fußball konzentrieren konnte. Er hat durchblicken lassen, dass das die Situation beeinflusst. Jetzt sind wir da, wo wir sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob das mit der Unruhe im Umfeld so gut ist, trotz meines Optimismus.
Es ist bitter. Wir hätten jetzt genau die Zeit, die wir gesprochen haben, über das Fernprojekt Karlsruhe und das laufende Gerichtsverfahren. Das ist das viel, viel wichtigere Thema. Aber dazu gibt es auch andere Berichterstattung. Das kann man sich erlesen. Und wenn es da eine Entscheidung gibt, dann hoffe ich, dass ich es in den Rasenfunk heben kann. Aber wir haben ja schon im letzten Mal, als wir gesprochen haben, verlief das Gespräch genauso. Nämlich, dass tausend Namen flogen durch den Raum. Und immer waren es die Vizepräsidenten, waren sich uneinig mit dem Rest. Das waren Minderheitenentscheidungen. Jetzt musste er gehen, Oliver Kreuzer usw. Aber wenn du jetzt mal versuchen müsstest, was natürlich schwierig ist, weil du bist ja auch weit weg, auch wenn du ganz tief in der Materie drin bist. Aber wie würdest du das denn jetzt einordnen? Sind das hier Machtspiele? Geht es darum, dass es da unterschiedliche Wege gibt, die man beschreiten möchte? Sind das vielleicht auch einfach nur große Egos, die aufeinander preien? Also bei aller Vorsicht natürlich. Es ist schwierig, das von außen zu beurteilen. Aber was wäre denn dein vorläufiges Fazit, warum ist so viel Unruhe beim KSC, wo man doch eigentlich Grund dachte zu haben, dass man sich jetzt mal wieder aufs Sportliche konzentrieren kann und es jetzt vorangeht?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich würde sagen, es ist wirklich so eine Mixtur aus allem, was du angesprochen hast. Das sind auf jeden Fall Egos, das sind auf jeden Fall Machtspiele. Definitiv. Die ganzen 3 zu 2 Entscheidungen im Präsidium, da geht es vor allem um Macht, natürlich, definitiv. Und ich glaube, was man auch nicht unterschätzen darf, ist diese finanzielle Geschichte. Speziell der Vizepräsident Martin Müller hat durch eigenes Geld ca. 5 Mio. ermöglicht, dass der Vorhergutpräsident, der Merkel des deutschen Fußballs war, so ein Stück weit, wo gar nichts voran ging, Ingo Wellenreuter, dass der gehen musste. Und das hat er damals aber noch mit der Hilfe von den Fans gemacht, sondern den Supporters. Dementsprechend war es jetzt für die schwierig, sich von dem abzusetzen gewissermaßen. Und am Ende des Tages, das ist total schwierig, weil ich bin mir bei der neuen Struktur auch nicht sicher. Also ich persönlich hätte lieber einen ganz normalen Geschäftsführersport beispielsweise. Weil ob das so perspektivisch funktionieren kann, kann ich überhaupt nicht sagen. Ich kann nur sagen, dass Oliver Kreuzer im Endeffekt den Job erfüllt hat. Er hat die Klasse gehalten, immer. Rein vom Budget her sind wir genau da, wo wir gerade stehen ungefähr. Und dementsprechend ist es auf jeden Fall ein mutiger Schritt, den vor allem dann der Präsident eingeleitet hat. Also Holger Sigmund Schulze, indem er diese Abstimmung über Oliver Kreuzer forciert hat. Und mit den ganzen Konsequenzen. Und das Ergebnis, wenn man ehrlich ist, mindestens erst im nächsten Sommer sehen. Das meinte ich vorhin, man kann eigentlich die Transferbilanz von KSC überhaupt nicht beurteilen, richtig. Weil es von der Task Force, die so ein bisschen improvisiert hat, arbeiten müssen.
Genau, also soll man Sebastian Freis dafür kritisieren, dass er zwischen August und Ende August nichts mehr hinbekommen hat. Und der KD jetzt an manchen Stellen ein bisschen zu dünn ist. Er hat den natürlich vorher auch schon in der Task Force mitzusprechen. Aber ja, es ist, also auf mich wirkt das so, wie eine riesengroße vergebene Chance. Weil man eben, Stadion ist fertig, Lars Stindl kehrt zurück. Du hast einen Trainer, Christian Eichner, wir haben jetzt überhaupt nicht über Christian Eichner gesprochen, müssen wir nämlich auch gar nicht. Der ist nämlich super, der ist genau am richtigen Ort. Und letztlich hast du auch mit Sebastian Freis jemand, wo glaube ich ganz viele KSC-Fans sagen, ja super, gehen wir mit. Weil auch der ist am richtigen Ort und hat eben zumindest als Spieler eben noch, als ehemaliger Spieler einen positiven Leum. Und auf mich wirkt das so, als ob man durch dieses Ganze hin und her vielleicht eine Chance vergibt, die so schnell auch nicht wiederkommen könnte beim KSC. Ich meine, ich lasse mich gerne eines Besseren belehren, aber das ist so mein Außenblick, den ich habe auf Karlsruhe.
Also das zum einen oder hier zum Abschluss vielleicht, also was es auf jeden Fall geben muss in irgendeiner Form, ist ein reinigendes Gewitter bei dieser Mitgliederversammlung. Weil so wie es aktuell ist, kann es eigentlich nicht weitergehen. Weil die werden das immer wieder öffentlich austragen, über die Medien beispielsweise. Also entweder es verändert sich das Präsidium, entweder es tritt ein komplettes neues Präsidium an, was ich mir nicht vorstellen kann aktuell. Aber da muss auf jeden Fall was geschehen in irgendeiner Form. Weil wenn die permanent streiten, zieht man nicht an einem Strang und dann geht es ja auch nicht voran. Also das ist glaube ich das, was man auf jeden Fall festhalten kann. Es wird was passieren und es wird glaube ich spannend.
Was hast du gesagt, 9. Dezember ist die? Okay, also das markieren wir uns schon mal mal gucken. Vielleicht musst du dann noch mal kommen und dann bringe ich wieder mein Board mit und frische Stecknadeln und neues Garn. Und dann kannst du mir erzählen, was bei House of Karlsruhe in der Sonderstaffel passiert ist. Aber das gucken wir uns ganz in Ruhe an, so wie wir uns ja ganz in Ruhe eure drei Vereine angeguckt haben. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Das war total interessant zu hören, wie unterschiedlich und doch ähnlich manche sich hier waren. Nur mit dem KSC konnte niemand mithalten. Aber das ist vielleicht in dem Fall gar nicht so schlecht.
Vielleicht gibt es beim Club auch bald ein kleines House of Karlsruhe. Ich sag nur Raphael Schäfer, Aufsichtsrat. Da hätten wir auch ein paar nicht so krass sportliche Themen, Max. Aber das wollen wir doch heute nicht nur aufhören.
Also Raphael Schäfer möchte in den Aufsichtsrat, seh ich das richtig?
Ja, und er wird in den Aufsichtsrat kommen.
Und es gibt da auch ein paar Themen abseits des Sportlichen. Aber es ist schön, dass wir darüber gar nicht uns beschäftigt haben. Also finde ich super, dass das auch noch ein bisschen hin, bis es so weit kommt. Aber Michi ist im Bilde.
Okay, alles klar. Also ich weiß, dass das gewisse Leute hören. Ruft mich einfach an, erklärt mir das. Ich weiß, dass ihr die Segmente zum Club immer hört. Und dann hole ich mir da die Infos dann eben dann off-air und dann überlege ich, was ich davon wieder reinhole. Aber ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich für eure Zeit. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Lisa Höfer. Danke, dass du hier warst.
Danke, dass es geklappt hat, Max. Super viel Spaß gemacht. Zeit ist verflogen und gerne wieder.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall. Dann mit Raphael Schäfer im Aufsichtsrat, nach dem, was ich jetzt gerade gehört habe. Herzlichen Dank auch an Michael Fischer. Auch nochmal ganz besonders, ohne jetzt zu verraten. Aber das ist ein ganz spezieller Aufnahmetermin für dich. Danke, dass du mit dabei warst.
Sehr, sehr gerne. Und vielleicht bist du zur Schlusskonferenz im nächsten Jahr.
Ja, Schlusskonferenz gibt es ja nicht mehr. Aber ich weiß, glaube ich, was du damit andeuten möchtest. Es gibt die Rasenfunk-Bundesliga der Männer.
Für mich ist das immer noch die Schlusskonferenz.
Ich bin schon alt. Schlusskonferenz always in our heart. In meinem auch noch so ein bisschen, muss ich es sagen. Und ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Jörn Kreuzer. Niemand hatte mehr Notizzettel dabei mit dazu. Aber niemand hat sie auch so sehr gebraucht wie du. Weil das ist ja wirklich kompliziert. Danke dir, Jörn, dass du mit dabei warst.
Und ich hoffe, dass es nicht so ausufernd war.
Wir danken dir und die Hörerinnen und Hörer. Die werden uns das schon sagen. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörer, auf rasen.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Unter mitmachen.rasen.de könnt ihr Feedback geben. Und auf rasen.de findet ihr generell alle Sendungen, die wir so aufgenommen haben. Also Frauen-Bundesliga und Männer-Bundesliga haben wir ja gemacht. Borussia Dortmund Schwerpunkt gibt es. Copa Libertadores habe ich gestern aufgenommen. Und wenn alles gut geht, wird am Freitag oder Samstag noch ein Tribüngespräch erscheinen. Jaha, wir hören nicht auf zu senden. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund, macht's gut.
Ciao!
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.